let's bring in Texas Republican
Congressman chip Roy who serves on the
Judiciary Committee he says he's
skipping a GOP trip to the Border
tomorrow because it's time to quote act
with urgency uh Congressman it's great
to have you on yes as we kind of noted
there the house speaker is bringing down
a group of uh Republican house members
to The Border you want to skip it and
precisely why are you not
going yeah first of all Trey's great to
be on Happy New Year and and I want to
give a strong shout out to speaker
Johnson uh for his leadership I'm I'm
totally happy with him taking uh members
of the Republican delegation down to the
Border if they don't know what's
actually happening in the Border after
watching all of Bill malan's great
reporting or if they don't understand
the depth of the crisis it'll be great
for them to hear from the ranchers from
the sheriffs from the local law
enforcement from the border patrol that
I talk to on a daily and weekly basis
it'd be great for them to learn but I'm
not going to go down and stare at these
people that I've been talking to for now
four four and a half years as a member
of Congress almost five years and and
not deliver and at this point right now
Republicans have an obligation to
deliver we delivered last spring when we
came together and we passed hr2 which
most people who are object objective
about it would tell you would actually
solve the problem and actually do what
needs to be done to honor our laws and
secure the Border but now we need to
deliver and and I got to be honest I was
on a phone call this morning with
sheriffs and border patrol Coalition
folks and ranchers this morning and they
said to me Congressman Roy you know
we've got to shut down the Border or yes
you should shut down the government
that's the way people feel about it
they're they're past uh being able to
accept what's happening to our country
300,000 in a month if we let that
continue until the next president is put
in office 3.6 million if only half of
those are released I think it may be
more now 1.8 million people released
into the United States plus Goda ways
which you just reported on we can't take
this anymore Texas spent 12 billion so
it's time for the Congress while I want
to put this up on the screen let me just
jump in because I want to put these on
the screen because the numbers are
important in this thing and I want to do
this is December 22 this is fiscal year
302,000 encounters as we just said but
you go to the bottom right
73,9 N4 Encounters in fiscal year in
December of 2021 that is three and a
half times this December three and a
half times what it was just three years
ago that is a massive
problem it is a massive problem and it's
purposeful I mean look people need to
understand this I hear some even
Republicans saying but chip you know
we're a nation of immigrants America
we're supposed to welcome people in yes
that is a part of our history but keep
in mind Trace 49 A5 million Americans
are foreign born okay right now that
puts us at about 15% of the population
which is as high as it's ever been in
our history of those folks they've got
about 16 to 20 million kids we're not
teaching our kids Western Civilization
we are not teaching our kids to believe
in the Constitution and believe in
America we are not forming a
capitalistic system where people are
coming here for hard work we're building
up a socialist system with a big safety
net that is about to break and all of us
who are working hard and the hardworking
people out there they're going to lose
what they inherited from their uh you
know ancestors in in this great country
so we've got to stop this it is
Republicans job to put up or shut up my
the people here are saying chip why
would you vote to fund the DHS that is
doing this to the people of Texas yeah
so that's the question on the table yeah
it's exactly right I mean listen I've
been covering the bo my first job was on
the border 37 years ago and the whole
concept of this is you can pass laws
until you're blue in the face until you
secure the actual physical border it's
not going to do anybody any good
Congressman it's great to have you on
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else